大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
今天這一集,
我們把耶魯大學的賽局理論公開課,
課號ECON159,
前面八堂課一起上完,
講臺上是Ben Pollack老師,
這八堂課都在回答同一個問題,
當你的結果不只有你決定,
你該怎麼選,
我先把答案放在前面,
難的不是算出自己要什麼,
是算出別人會怎麼做,
你要什麼,
通常你心裡有數,
可是別人在想什麼,
別人以為你在想什麼,
這才是這門課真正在練的功夫。
Polak上課不先教公式
他發開一張紙
讓全班先玩一場遊戲
第一堂課那張紙上
只有兩個字母
2007年秋天
耶魯大學的第一堂賽局理論課
Ben Polak走進教室
先發開一張紙
紙上寫著一個成績遊戲
你要在格子裡填一個字母
Alpha或是Beta
不能給旁邊的人看
老師會把你的紙
跟另一個同學的紙
隨機配成一對
你們兩個永遠不會知道
對方是誰
規則只有四行
你填Alpha
對方填Beta
你拿A
對方拿C
都拿B減
你填Beta
對方填Alpha
你拿C
對方拿A
兩個人都填Beta
兩個人都拿B加
Polak把這四行
畫成一張表
橫的是你的選擇
直的是對方的選擇
每一格填上
兩個人的成績
他問全班
填Alpha的請舉手
舉起來的手
多到數不完
你會填哪一個
Polak請舉手的同學
說說理由
有一個女生站起來
她說等那句話
後來變成這門課的第一課
她說
不管對方填什麼
我填Alpha的結果都比較好
C B-B C 好
假設對方填Beta
你填Alpha拿A
你填Beta拿B加
A比B加好
兩欄都是同一個答案
這種情況有一個名字
叫Secret Dominance
中文叫嚴格優勢
它的意思是
不管別人做什麼
這一步都比那一步好
Polak說
這個理由比另一位同學的強得多
因為另一位同學是先猜
對方會填Alpha
才決定自己也填Alpha
這個女生根本不必猜
於是第一課寫上黑板
你不要去打一個
被嚴格壓過的選擇
第一課聽起來很安全
可是你再看一次那張表
全班大部分人都填了Alpha
結果呢
兩個人都填Alpha
兩個人都拿B-
如果兩個人都填Beta
B-比B-好
每個人都做了對自己最好的選擇
最後大家一起掉到比較差的地方
這就是第二課理性的選擇會通向壞結果
這個局面有一個名字叫Prisoner's Dilemma
中文叫囚徒困境
Polak舉了一個你一定有感覺的例子
宿舍
你跟室友合住一間房間
到學題末那間房間通常很慘
為什麼
因為如果室友不收你更不享受
你最不願意的事就是替別人收
如果室友收了
房間本來就乾淨
你也不用動
兩邊算下來
你都不會收
那再留到學題結束
這裡有件事要先講清楚
Paulak說
剛剛那張成績表
其實還不算一場遊戲
他有玩家
有可以做的選擇
也有每一種組合的結果
可是他少了一樣東西
少的是pay off
中文叫報酬
也就是每個人心裡真正在乎的東西
你只在乎自己的成績嗎
還是對方拿C你也會難過
Paulak把在乎的東西換掉
重新算一次
他假設你拿A
對方拿C的時候
你會有罪惡感
晚上睡不好
你拿C
對方拿A的時候
你除了難過
還會覺得不公平
同一張表
同一批選擇
只是換了在乎的東西
Alpha就不再壓過Beta
全班的手也真的分成兩半
所以第三課是
你得先弄清楚自己要什麼
才談得上怎麼拿到
接下來Polak
做了一件很聰明的事
他把兩種人混在一起
假設你只在乎自己的成績
可是你知道對面那個人
會有罪惡感
你怎麼選
再翻過來
假設你是會有罪惡感的那種人
對面坐的是
是一隻在乎成績的人
你又怎麼選
第二種情況比較有意思
你自己這邊
沒有一個穩贏的選擇
Alpha不壓過Beta
可是你把眼睛
移到對方那一欄
你會發現
對他來說
Alpha壓過Beta
他一定填Alpha
你知道他會填Alpha
你就知道自己該填Alpha
這就是第四課
也是這門課
真正難的地方
你要坐到對方的位置上
用他在乎的東西
替他算一次賬
順帶一提
那天耶魯有238個人
填Alpha
36個人填Beta
Paulak笑著說
第五課是耶魯的學生很自私
第一堂課結束前
Paul Lark又發了第二張紙
這次的題目更好玩
你要寫下一到一百之間的一個整數
老師會算出全班的平均數
最接近平均數三分之二的人贏
獎品是一張五塊美金的鈔票
他當場放進信封
交給攝影師保管
你先自己想一下
你會寫幾
下一堂課
Paul Lark把大家的答案挑出來
有一批人寫在32到34之間
他請其中一個同學說理由
那個同學說
如果大家亂寫
平均大概是50
50的三分之二
大概是33
所以我寫33
這個推理聽起來很順
Polak也說他不是壞答案
他是一個很好的起點
可是他的第一句話就錯了
錯在哪裡
在回答之前
Polak先講了一個更古老的故事
是一元前三世紀
Hannibal要帶軍隊翻進羅馬
他有兩條路可以走
一條是翻山的南路
就要折損一個軍團
另一條沿著海岸走
好走
不折損
你是守方
你只守得住其中一條
你守哪一條
全班大多數人舉手
守好走的那一條
Polak問
好走的那一條
有壓過難走的那一條嗎
沒有
如果對方真的走山路
你守在海邊就撲空了
那為什麼大家都選對
因為大家其實已經算過
對方那一欄
從他的角度看
走好走的路
最差的情況跟走山路一樣
最好的情況比走山路好
他當然走好走的路
你算出他會走哪一條
你就知道自己該守哪一條
我們回到那個猜數字的題目
那句錯的話是
如果大家亂寫
Paulak請全班互相看一看
他說你們有誰長得像一臺
隨機數字產生器
大家都想贏
大家都在算
那就一層一層往下走
第一層
沒有人會寫超過67
因為就算全班通常寫100
平均的三分之二也只有66點多
寫更大的數字
永遠比不上寫67
68以上等於不存在
第二層
既然沒有人寫超過67
平均最多就是67
三分之二大概是45
45以上也可以刪掉
第三層刪到30
第四層刪到20
這個手法有個名字叫反覆刪除
意思是刪掉沒人會選的
再回頭看一次
再刪一次
你一直刪下去
最後只剩下一
那天全班的答案是多少
平均是13
又三分之一
三分之二剛好是9
寫9的那幾個同學站起來領獎
5塊錢分成9份
有意思的是寫1的人是全班最多的
可是他們沒贏
為什麼
為什麼3到底反而不對
因為3到1需要的條件很重
你要理性
你要知道別人理性
你要知道別人知道你理性
一路無限往上
這種狀態
叫common knowledge
中文叫共識
Polak請兩位助教上臺
各戴一頂粉紅色的帽子
兩個人都看得到對方頭上是粉紅色
可是誰也看不到自己頭上那一頂
所以臺上兩個人都知道有粉紅色的帽子
卻沒有人敢說
對方也知道
後來Polak讓全班再玩一次
這一次每個人寫的數字都更小
變得不只是你會算了
是你知道旁邊每個人也都會算了
Polak把同一套想法搬到政治上
他在黑板上畫一條線
上面有十個位置
1號是最左邊
10號是最右邊
他假設每個位置都住著全部選民的10%
假設每個選民都投給離自己最近的候選人
假設兩個候選人都想拿到最多的票
你是其中一個候選人
你站哪裡
Polak問全班
有沒有哪個位置根本不該站
一個同學回答
1號和10號
你算一次1號跟2號的差別
你佔2號對方佔1號
1號那邊的人投給他
剩下9層全部投給你
你佔1號對方佔2號
只有1號那邊的人投給你
對方不管佔哪裡
1號都比1號多拿5個百分點
所以2號壓過1號
又變得道理一樣
9號壓過10號
1號和10號刪掉之後
有位同學舉手說
那再看一次呢
這是關鍵的一步
在原本的遊戲裡
2號並沒有被3號壓過
因為萬一對方佔1號佔2號
會比佔3號多拿票
可是既然1號不會有人佔
這個萬一就消失了
於是2號被3號壓過
9號被8號壓過
你再上一次
3號和8號也走了
再一次
4號和7號也走了
最後整條線上
只剩下5號和6號
兩個人肩並肩站在正中間
這個結論在政治學裡有名字
叫Median Voter Theorem
中文叫中間選民定理
他說決定選舉結果的
是站在中間的那一小群人
Paulak舉了一個老例子
你今天回去看
1960年Kennedy跟Nixon的辯論錄影
會很驚訝
Kennedy講起話來有多保守
兩個人都在往中間擠
同一個模型
換一個場景
你每天都看得到
你有沒有想過
加油站
為什麼老是擠在同一個路口
照理說加油站
平均散在城市各處
對大家最方便
你車子在哪裡快沒油
附近就有一家
可是現實不是這樣
他們常常兩三家
擠在同一個十字路口
原因跟剛剛那條線一模一樣
你如果自己搬遠一點
離你比較近的客人就變少了
對手會把你這邊的客人
一口氣接走
你不敢離開
對手也不敢離開
兩邊就這樣黏在一起
這個想法在經濟學裡
出現得更早
1919年就有一位
叫Hotelling的學者寫過
政治學那邊是
1957年的Anthony Downs
同一件事
兩個領域各自想到一次
Polak
記得做了一件
我很喜歡的事
他把模型放在臺上
然後請全班一起挑他的毛病
同學講出來的有這些
選民不是平均分佈在一條線上
不是每個人都會去投票
真實選舉常常不止兩個候選人
政治也不是隻有
左跟右一個方向
還有外交
環境
還有候選人的人品
Polak自己補了一個
最要命的
這個模型
假設候選人想站哪就站哪
可是你相信嗎
一個有記錄的人
突然說自己在中間
選民通常不買賬
他舉了英國的例子
工黨連輸好幾次選舉
每次都說我們已經是中間路線了
沒有人信
後來Tony Blair的做法很極端
他把對手政府
未來五年的財政計劃
整份拿過來
說這就是我的計劃
他不是說自己在中間
他是把位置真的搬過去
Polak在課堂上說
接下來要講
世界上最重要的一場遊戲
全班安靜下來
他說
是足球的十二碼罰球
踢的人有三個選擇
或鋪右邊
他先把進球的幾率
填進一張表
你踢左邊
守門員鋪左邊
幾率最低
你踢左邊
他鋪右邊
幾率最高
踢右邊剛好反過來
踢中間呢
不管他鋪哪一邊
幾率都落在中間
不高也不低
你先看一點這張表
有沒有哪個選擇
被完全壓過
沒有
踢中間在他鋪左邊的時候
比踢左邊好
在他鋪右邊的時候
又比踢右邊差
用前面的號刪除的方法
你在這張表上一步也走不動
可是這是最重要的遊戲
總不能什麼都說不出來
Pluck換了一個工具
他在黑板上畫一張圖
橫軸是你相信守門員往右撲的幾率
從0到1
縱軸是你的進球幾率
你踢左邊畫出一條線
踢右邊畫出另一條線
踢中間畫出第三條
全班一看就看懂了
中間那條線
從頭到尾都被壓在另外兩條下面
這代表什麼
這代表不管你心裡怎麼想守門員
不管你覺得他往右撲的機會是1層還是9層
踢中間都不會是你最好的選擇
這個概念叫best response
中文叫最佳回應
意思是在你相信對方會怎麼做的前提下
你能走得最好的一步
所以這一堂課的結論很短
你不要踢中間
Polak還補了一句
除非你是德國人
這一段講完之後
Polak又把模型放下來
檢查一次
他說有人真的去查了實際比賽的資料
論文登在美國經濟評論上
作者是Caporey
跟幾位合作者
真實數字跟他黑板上邊的數字很接近
只有一個差別
射手往自己順角的方向踢
進球率確實高一點點
全班還挑出別的毛病
守門員其實可以站著不動
射手還可以選擇踢高踢低
有一位同學講到一件更要緊的事
你不只選方向
你還選要踢多大力
Polak說這個很關鍵
如果你是那種球踢得很重
但是不太準的人
往兩邊踢比較容易射偏
往中間踢
反而因為球速太快守不住
把這件事划進圖裡
中間那條線的一小段就冒出頭來了
同一堂課的下半場
Polak換了一個你更用得到的例子
合夥
兩個人合開一家事務所
利潤一人一半
可是利息各出各的
你多花一小時
公司多賺一點
這很直接
除此之外
還有一項你們兩個一起做
會比各做各的多賺一些
因為你擅長的地方
剛好補上他不會的
這一項有一個名字叫忠孝
Polak
請大家算出一件事
如果對方出的利益是某個數字
你出多少利益對自己最好
算出來是一條往上走的線
對方越攀你也越想攀
把兩個人的線
畫在同一張圖上
焦點就
兩個人同時在對對方
做最佳回應的地方
這種你多做
我也想多做的關係
Polak給了一個名字
叫策略互補
算出來之後
Polak問了一個更實際的問題
這個出力的程度
是多了還是少了
答案是少了兩個合夥人出的力
會比整體最好的程度還低
為什麼
有同學說
因為對方會偷懶
Polak說這個方向對
可是還沒說到點上
真正的原因是這樣
你多做一小時
這一小時的辛苦全部是你的
可是這一小時多賺的錢
你只拿一半
另外一半進了對方口袋
你在算自己這一步的時候
那一半根本不在你的賬上
經濟學把這件事叫外部性
你回頭看第一堂課
那間沒人收拾的宿舍
是同一回事
成本自己扛
好處大家分
這裡也是
只要利潤要分
出力就會偏少
跟人品沒什麼關係
兩條最佳回應線
交匯的那個點
有一個名字
它叫Nash Equilibrium
中文叫Nash均衡
它的定義只有一句話
每一個人的選擇
都是對其他人選擇的最佳回應
Polakke的兩種聽得懂的說法
第一種叫沒有後悔
你隔天早上醒來
已經知道別人做了什麼
你回頭看自己那一步
你不會想改
第二種叫自我實現的預期
如果每個人都相信別人會照這個組合走
那每個人真的就會照這個組合走
因為那正好是自己最划算的一步
Polak特別提醒一句
這不代表人一定會走到均衡
全班玩猜數字的時候
均衡是1
真正的答案是9
均衡是一種很有用的預測
不是一條鐵律
Polak又讓全班玩一場
規則是這樣
你可以投10塊錢
也可以不投
不投的人不賺不賠
投了的人要看全班的結果
如果全班有9成以上的人投
你拿回15塊
等於淨賺5塊
如果不到9成
你那10塊錢就沒了
中間不準討論
不準打暗號
你會投嗎
第一次舉手
全班大概一半一半
Polak問了幾個人
有人說我投
因為不投永遠不可能賺到東西
有人說我不投
因為要賺這五塊
得先賭九成的人跟我一樣
賠的時候卻是整整十塊
兩種算法都說得通
問題是一半一半離九成很遠
這一局所有投錢的人都賠
這場遊戲有幾個均衡
有同學回答得很好
兩個
一個是所有人都投
大家都賺
沒有人想改
另一個是所有人都不投
大家都沒事
也沒有人想改
因為如果別人都不投
你自己跳下去就是白賠
兩個都是納許均衡
可是一個明顯比另一個好
Polak讓全班再玩第二次
第三次舉手的人越來越少
第三次幾乎沒有人投
全班一路滑到比較差的均衡
為什麼會往下不往上
因為第一次就已經在九成以下了
沒投的人發現自己做對了
就繼續不投
投的人發現自己賠了
下一次也不投
Polak說
如果第一次剛好有九成三的人投
這班很可能一路往上滑到好的那一邊
這裡有一個容易混掉的地方
全班掉到壞結果
看起來很像第一堂課的囚徒困境
可是他不是
在囚徒困境裡
不合作那一步永遠比較好
怎麼算都一樣
在這裡不是
如果全班都投
你跟著投就會賺
你的選擇跟著別人的選擇跑
這種局面叫協調問題
Polak說他在社會上到處都是
一種難看的流行
大家一起穿
一套不見得最好的軟體
大家一起用
因為別人都在用
你的檔案才打得開
一種電視規格
大家一起選
最戲劇化的一個例子
叫銀行擠兌
銀行把你的存款
借出去賺利息
只要大家有信心
把錢留在裡面
這是好的均衡
只要大家開始害怕
一起跑去領錢
銀行手上根本沒有那麼多現金
他就真的倒
我們回到銀行擠兌這件事
2007年那個秋天
英國一家叫Northern Rock的銀行
正在發生擠兌
報紙上就有存戶在門口排隊的照片
Paul Lager也提到電影《風雲人物》
片子裡的銀行沒有倒
因為Jimmy Stewart站出來
跟大家把話講清楚
然後他做了一件很妙的事
他把麥克風交給一位同學
給他五秒鐘
讓他對全班說話
那位同學只說了一句
如果我們都投了
大家都比較好
所以大家都投吧
接著再玩一次
幾乎全班都投了
同一場遊戲
玩第四次
結果整個翻過來
他沒有給錢
沒有簽約
沒有威脅任何人
他只是把話說出來
在囚徒困境裡
這種話一點用都沒有
在協調問題裡
這種話
可以把大家一起搬到
另一個均衡
這就是領導幫得上忙的地方
下一堂課
Polak
說要幫大家解決約會的問題
一對男女約在電影院碰面
有三部片可以選
兩個人忘了先講好
要看哪一部
進場前也聯絡不上
你先看一眼
有沒有
哪一部一定不用考慮
有
第三部片是兩個人
都最不想一起看的
不管對方去哪一部
你選他都比較差
直接刪掉
剩下兩部
兩個人碰到一起
才有分數
各走各的就是零分
所以這裡有兩個
納許均衡都去看第一部
或者都去看第二部
麻煩在後面
女生比較想看第一部
男生比較想看第二部
這跟投資遊戲不一樣
那場遊戲裡
好的均衡是大家公認的好
這裡兩個人喜歡的均衡不是同一個
這種局面
有一個名字叫性別之戰
接下來這個模型很老
1838年就有了
作者是法國人Cornot
比Nash早了大概100年
場景是兩家公司賣一模一樣的東西
就當作瓶裝水
他們要決定的不是價格
是產量
各自決定要生產多少瓶
市場上的水越多
價格就越低
這是需求區現在做的事
每一家的利潤
等於賣價減成本
在層上自己賣掉的瓶數
Polak一樣
先算最佳回應
對方生產的越多
是往下走的
你回想一下合夥那個例子
那裡的線往上
對方越攀你越想攀
這裡剛好相反
這種你多做我就少做的關係
叫策略替代
兩條往下的線交在一起
就是這個市場的納許均衡
均衡算出來之後
Polar問了一個很商業的問題
這兩家公司能不能私下講好
各做一半
價格撐高
兩邊一起多賺
表面上可以
有同學馬上說
那是違法的
確實違法
可是我們先把法律放一邊
就算他們真的講好了
這個約定也撐不住
你把自己放進去算一次
假設對方守約只做一半
那你的最佳回應是什麼
多做一點
把多出來的錢賺走
對方也不笨
他知道你會多做
所以他也先多做一點
你知道他知道你會多做
你就再多做一點
一路推下去
兩邊又回到原本那個均衡
你有沒有覺得這個推法很眼熟
這就是猜數字那一堂課的
一層一層往下
只是這次推的不是數字
是產量
就算偷跑的問題解決了
還有一件事擋在前面
價格撐高
利潤就高
利潤一高
外面的人就看得見
Polec說1900年前後的美國
很多產業真的簽過限制產量的協議
紙 鋼 鐵 橡膠 鐵軌都有
結果呢
新的公司看到有錢賺
一家一家開進來
價格還是被壓下去
他也給了一個離現在比較近的例子
1970年代
OPEC把幾個主要產油國組織起來
講好限制產量
油價撐住了
接下來發生什麼事
英國跑去北海賺油
拉丁美洲一堆國家開始找油
蘇聯的石油變得非常好賺
你們幾個把價格撐住
賺錢的不一定只有你們
這是這個模型最現實的一句話
同一個市場
Polak
換了一個問法
剛剛兩家公司決定的是產量
這次他們決定的是價格
賣掉多少由市場決定
你先算自己的最佳回應
如果對方的定價高於成本
你怎麼做最好
你把價格定的比他低一點點
就一點點
整個市場的客人全部走到你這邊來
而且每一筆你都還有賺
對方也會這樣想
於是你降一點
他再降一點
一路降到哪裡
降到成本
這個市場的納許均衡
是兩家公司都把價格定在成本上
利潤是零
你注意一下這個結果有多極端
市場上只有兩家公司
只比獨佔多一家
可是消費者拿到的價格
跟有一千家公司在競爭的時候一模一樣
這個模型叫Betrend競爭
這個結果讓Polak自己也不安
同一個市場
只是把公司在決定的東西
從產量換成價格
結論就從中間跑到極端
他說這件事真的讓人不放心
因為真實世界
不會因為你換一種想法就變樣
救回來的辦法是把現實加回去
前面兩家公司賣的是一模一樣的水
可是真實的商品幾乎都不一樣
他畫了一條街
一家店開在街頭
一家店開在街尾
客人平均住在這條街上
你買東西不只付錢
你還要走過去走得越遠越麻煩
所以離你近的那一家
就算貴一點你也可能買
同一條線也可以不是距離
而是啤酒的口味 飲料的甜度
你最愛的口味在這一點
喝到別的口味你也付出了一點代價
Polak
接著把選舉模型整個改掉
前面那個模型
假設候選人想站哪就站哪
這次他反過來假設
後選人的位置改不了
而且每一個選民
都可能自己跳出來參選
他挑了一整排同學
當這條政治光譜
最左邊那個是最左派
最右邊那個是最右派
規則是這樣
他站起來就是參選
參選要付一筆錢
選上有一筆獎金
不管誰選上
那個人離你越遠
你心裡越不舒服
他請大家閉上眼睛數到三
要參選的人站起來
第一次
站起來的有個偏左的
一箇中間偏左的
一個站在中間的
中間那個贏了
跑大棍
這是均衡嗎
不是
因為偏左那位站起來也選不上
他坐著反而好
至少省下那筆參選的錢
這個模型馬上長出一個很真實的結論
假設場上有一個中間偏左的候選人
和一個中間偏右的候選人
兩邊票數差不多
這時候有一位更左邊的人決定跳出來選
他當然選不上
可是他會把偏左那位的票分掉一部分
最後贏的是右邊那位
他站出來換來的是一個離他更遠的人當選
Polak說你回頭看
一零零年的美國總統大選
Nader參選之後發生什麼事
把票算一次就知道了
他還說
那天早上的報紙上
共和黨內部正在吵同一件事
如果Giuliani拿到提名
右派可能自己推一個人出來選
那樣的結果很可能是Hillary贏
這不是哪一邊的問題
兩邊完全對稱
既然候選人不一定會擠在中間
那他們最遠可以離多遠
Polak
把整條政治光譜切成六等份來算
假設左邊那位站在六分之一的位置
右邊那位站在六分之五
這時候如果有人從正中間跳出來選
選民會分成三份
左邊三分之一
中間三分之一
右邊三分之一
中間那位剛好有機會贏
可是隻要左右兩位
稍微往中間靠一點點
他們各自的地盤就超過三分之一
中間那個人就擠不進來
他當然不會出來
所以答案是
兩個候選人
最遠可以站在六分之一和六分之五
他們不會被擠到正中間
也不會跑到最極端
只要離得太開
中間就會有人跳進來
而且會贏
最後一堂課
Polak換了一個完全不同的題目
他說有兩個鎮
一個叫東鎮
一個叫西鎮
每個鎮住得下一樣多的人
世界上有兩種人
高的人和矮的人
人數一樣多
他把教師前半部指定成矮的人
後半部指定成高的人
然後給每個人一樣的心理偏好
你最喜歡的情況是
你住的鎮剛好一半跟你同一種人
一半是另一種人
你最討厭的情況是
整個鎮只有你一個是你這一種
如果沒辦法剛好一半一半
你寧可待在自己這種人比較多的那個鎮
請你注意這一點
這裡沒有任何人討厭另一種人
所有人其實都偏好混住
接下來他請全班閉上眼睛
選一個鎮
Horak先給全班一個接近一半一半的起點
只是稍微偏一點點
第一次舉手
兩個鎮的人開始往兩邊挪
第二次形狀更清楚了
第三次
整間教室乾乾淨淨的分成兩班
前面全部是矮的人
後面全部是高的人
每個人都拿到自己拿得到的比較好的結果
可是整體落挨個
所有人都不喜歡的狀態
Polak問全班
這叫什麼
有同學喊出來
隔離
這個模型有一個關鍵詞
叫tipping point
中文叫臨界點
一半一半
那個狀態其實也是一個均衡
可是它很脆弱
只要偏個5%
所有矮的人就想往東邊靠
所有高的人就想往西邊靠
幾步之內整個翻到底
這個模型是一位叫Sheldon的學者想出來的
他後來拿到諾貝爾經濟學獎
很大一部分就是因為他
Sheldon想提醒的事情是這樣
如果你走遍世界
發現每個社會都有隔離現象
你很容易推論說
因為大家喜歡隔離
可是這個模型告訴你
還有另一種可能
每個人其實都想住在混住的地方
只是沒有人願意當那個唯一的少數
光是這一點
加總起來就變成了隔離
你看到一個社會現象不代表那些人想要它
Polak說這在美國是很實際的政策問題
哈佛以前讓學生自己選宿舍
結果每一棟宿舍都長出一種味道
後來校方改成隨機分配
你不再自己選
反而大家都住進了混合的宿舍
最後Polak丟出一個
所有人都玩過的遊戲
石頭剪刀布
你先想一想
這個遊戲有沒有納許均衡
如果你固定出石頭
我就固定出布
你看到我固定出布
你就改出剪刀
我看到剪刀
我又改回石頭
繞了一圈回到原點
沒有任何一組固定的選擇
能互相站得住
所以到這裡為止
我們學的那些選擇
Polak給了他們一個名字
叫純策略
而這個遊戲在純策略裡沒有均衡
那答案是什麼
答案是三個各出三分之一
他在黑板上算給大家看
對上一個各出三分之一的人
你出石頭
出剪刀
出布
期望分數都是零
所以你也不如各出三分之一
把自己的選擇隨機化的做法
叫混合策略
也是終極的起點
我們回到開場那句話
這八堂課走下來
你看到的其實是
同一件事的不同面
第一堂課那樣紙上
你只要看自己的兩欄
就知道要填alpha
到了猜數字
你得算別人算到第幾層
到了罰球
你得知道守門員心裡在想什麼
到了合夥
到了兩家賣水的公司
到了選舉
每一步都是在回答同一個問題
別人會怎麼做
所以這一節的答案是
男的不是算出自己要什麼
是算出別人會怎麼做
可是這八堂課還留下另一半
也是比較難受的那一半
每個人都做了對自己最好的選擇
房間還是沒人收
蓋頭的錢沒人投
想混住的人卻住成了兩個陣
好的結果
不會因為每個人都聰明就自動出現
終結我們會繼續往下上
Polak
演化怎麼把賽局玩出來
講有先後順序的賽局
還有承諾跟威脅
為什麼有時候
才是真正有用的一步
最後問你一個問題
如果你現在正卡在一個
所有人都不滿意
卻誰也不敢先動的局面裡
你會先動嗎
留言告訴我
喜歡這種
把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jam
我們下次見